Cool. We are now live.
You can
who wants to drive this? You want to
share your screen, or will I share mine?
I'll put in Slack just there.
I think I have to set up the
permissions for
the app to share screens.
Let's see. Have you had any problems with
it sharing screens
in Chrome?
You'll just need to open the accessibility
security privacy settings and enable screen sharing for
Chrome.
At in at the OSX level? Or Yeah.
In OSX level. So if you open preferences
and then go to
security and privacy,
and there is a screen recording
k. In the list, and then you can
just enable Chrome there. You don't actually need
to restart Chrome. You can you can just
ignore that border.
Gotcha.
Third time's a charm I have.
Hey. Alright. Cool.
Cool. You okay if I just put that
live now?
Sure. You can take your time. That's not
a rush. Alright. No. I'm yeah.
So
we now have a screen. We're creating a
repository.
And so the repository, we're gonna create I
don't know if there's a naming convention for
GitHub actions.
Let's go with
what?
Packet host project leader. Maybe we'll just call
it prod project Packet project.
And
later on, if this gets promoted
to
Packet
Packet Labs, then we'll maybe we'll drop off
the the Packet prefix.
All of the p letter
alliteration,
I'm very, like, aware of it when I'm
wearing headphones.
And it's like
and we'll
get started with all of these things.
Apache work for you?
I mean, I'm more of an MIT person,
but, you know,
I but I whenever I publish code, I
generally just, like, do whatever you want with
it. And I check MIT is probably the
most permissive license.
Yeah.
Yeah. I I tend to for things like
this, I tend to go with whatever license
is most common for that project type,
and I haven't done my research on this
one. But I'll I'll
reserve the right to change it later.
Packet project. That couldn't be confused for anything
else.
Alright. So let's see. What what do have
to do to create a GitHub action?
It should be premise what what it is
that we're trying to do here.
That might help one too. So
Marcus and I were just discussing.
We have this thing, I guess, on Friday.
Let's go back in time. We have this
thing on Fridays, the packet, where we can
allocate some of our time to hack on
pack, where we just build our build proof
of concept in things that we think are
gonna be useful internally and externally for people
who use the packet. And Marcus has an
idea that solves a common problem, and I'll
let you take it from there.
Yeah. So the the problem is that there
are a lot of different
open source packet projects
that have
the need for some end to end testing.
And whenever you have an end to end
testing environment,
you have the potential for
your provisioning to fail,
and that could leave behind artifacts that
are costly over time or
otherwise just get neglected or forgotten and could
become security risks.
So you wanna make sure that you're cleaning
up these,
failed artifact resources.
In Terraform, they have a concept called a
sweeper,
which is a set of, it's a an
extra testing step that runs, I believe, before
and after,
tests to
that is aware of the different resource labels
that,
indicate that a resource was created for testing.
So let's say you have a packet server
called
Terraform or TF test
foo,
then when the sweeper comes along, if it
sees anything named that way, it knows that
it's not supposed to be there, and it's
safe for it to delete it.
It's also possible
in
various environments to, say, delete
a
an entire project,
and that simplifies things because then you can
just say, do I have any projects matching
TF test something? I do. Let's delete it.
Now Packet
doesn't let you delete an entire project because
it wants you to confirm that the resources
that exist inside of that project are safe
to delete. So you have to delete them
one by one. In this case, we know
exactly what we want to delete. We're good.
And what we wanna do is make an
all purpose GitHub action
that can be used to
delete
a project
by
name. Maybe we could use this, filter syntax,
and maybe any projects that match a certain
name pattern can be deleted.
Or maybe
this tool might also be useful for creating
projects
and creating a project tokens project API tokens
for
for whatever your end to end testing environment
needs are.
So I think that this GitHub action has
maybe three things it could do.
The one that we're most
those three things are creating a project, deleting
a project, and creating project tokens. The thing
that we're most interested in right now is
just deleting a project. We can specify a
name for it and
let it go with that.
And so this is the first time creating
a GitHub action, so there's a lot of
unknowns.
Yeah.
I'm hoping it won't be terribly difficult.
So
I guess what we need to do first
is you've created a repository. So we just
initialize, like, a a gold project, I guess.
Like, before we have to get hub action,
I guess we still wanna be able to
run this locally.
Yeah. Let me add you as a collaborator
for what it's worth to.
Looks like that. Let me check this collaborator.
Oh, that's that's
gonna be my stop there. I I should
check my phone for that one. I don't
type it in. I won't do that, but
we'll just work with what we've got then.
So, yeah, let's start with some go.
Hey, Dan. Enjoying the stream.
Hey.
How many people can you have visually on
here? Can Dan join us? Up to 10.
If Dan wants to join us, he is
more than welcome to come and join us.
Come on, Dan. Don't be afraid.
If anyone wants to join or ask questions,
you can leave questions via Twitter, YouTube, or
Twitch. And if you want to join, drop
us a DM,
and we'll see what we can do. We
are kind of on a very tight schedule
as well. Yeah. This might be a to
be continued. Right? We've gotta jump off in
twenty five minutes.
Can you just zoom in in your terminal
a bit as well, please? Sure.
You're not even gonna, like, get Packet project
was possibly the worst repository name, I think.
Yeah.
What could it possibly do? Nobody knows.
And so let's see. The first thing, I
wonder if there's a GitHub actions
extension where you can just, like, create one.
We get all kinds of extensions. Right? We
have one for actions, GitHub actions.
I don't know if there's anything particularly special
about a GitHub action, though. Right? Like, it's
just a
command.
So I guess, in my head, what we
want is
say this is called packet sweeper.
We have a drunk packet sweeper and pass
in a product ID.
It would give you a list of the
it would give you a list of all
the resources that's potentially going to delete, and
then we could confirm it.
And then we can add the yellow flag
layer where it doesn't do the confirmation, and
it just starts deleting everything.
Yeah. So let's start with, like, aamain.com.
Yeah.
Can you just change your font size as
well? Oh, yeah. That's why.
Awesome. Perfect.
So what's the easiest way to consume the
Packet API from a Go project?
That would be Pack and Go.
So let's get that going in here.
For
git.com,
packing, toast,
packing go.
And this is just a client library? I'm
not familiar with packing go, so 'll need
to kinda keep it right here, but I'm
assuming that's a client library for speaking to
the API.
Yeah. That that's exactly what it is. It's
a client library for talking to the API.
We've got some examples
of it, which I can probably use to
work quickly provision
things.
Let me get this up and running.
There we go.
And
gonna need this project listing, Tim.
Alright.
This isn't specifying token, so we'll we'll need
support for tokens.
In the end,
we need this thing to take some parameters,
so we're gonna need to import OS.
And the first parameter that we're gonna be
interested in is the project ID.
So
project ID, what are we gonna call it?
Project
ID.
I'm gonna choose the environment. It's easy for
right now.
Because it's not being used. I've got every
possible winter in place.
We have a friend.
What's up, folks?
Hey,
Dan.
Happy to jump in here.
Awesome. This is a pretty sweet setup y'all
have going.
So this is just the most impromptu thing
I think we we've managed to do yet.
We were just, like, jumping on a Zoom,
and we're like, hey. We should, like, build
this thing. And then the next thing I
know, we are broadcasting it. And it's like,
you know,
I I I think that
it'll be fun.
So
then
then I there's a lot of cross playing
stuff in the past, including the cross playing
packet provider,
which
this will also be useful for for end
to end testing in that environment.
Yeah. For sure. I
I'm some of this packing guest stuff looks
pretty familiar as we're obviously using that for
all the stuff in the packet provider as
well. And it's nice to see
Marcus and I did a stream. I guess
it was over a month ago now working
on some of the packet provider stuff for
Crossplane
and trying to do some Tinker Bell stuff,
which we
debatably succeeded at.
But,
yeah, I'm excited to see
a little more focus on integrations and stuff
on the packet side. So I've definitely been
enjoying some of these streams lately you've been
doing, David. Oh, thank you. And I guess,
there's no big good thing to tell everyone
that you just agreed to join me on
the stream as well and we're gonna have
we're gonna be taking a look at the
seccomp operator, which I'm very excited about. Definitely.
Yeah. There's some super cool stuff. That's one
of the things in the one dot 19
release in Kubernetes,
came out Wednesday.
That that is one of the cooler
aspects, so excited to dive into that as
well.
Yeah. Set comp is one of those things
that I know I should be providing profiles
for applications, and then I'm just like, but
why is it so painful to do it?
Like Yeah. Yeah. No. That's a huge thing.
And, you know, the set comp operator addresses
some of that, but to be totally honest
with you, and we can get into this
more in that stream, but,
like, it's still hard to craft your seccomp
profiles. Right? So the operator is solving getting
those on your nodes and that sort of
thing in your cluster.
But we actually just had our first kinda,
like, community meeting for the seccomp operator yesterday,
and one of the things we're looking at
is
recording profiles. Right? So you can run your
pods and we'll record a profile and say,
hey. This is all the syscalls that your
process made while running. Would you like to,
you know, restart this with the profile applied,
and we'll put it on the node for
you? So those are all sorts of things
we're looking into, make that a little bit
easier.
So I tried to do that about nine
months ago, the start of the year, I
think it was. Mhmm. Using is way to
try and log all the syscalls that are
running.
Mhmm.
But then I I had to learn, you
know, eBPF, and that I was just like,
you know what? I I'm not doing this.
So Yeah. But there's someone else who's doing
it for me. Yeah. That's my preferred route
for everything. If someone else like, right now,
you know, Marcus is just sitting right on
the code, we just get to set chat.
So Yeah.
Yeah. This works for me. This is a
lot more relaxed than than some of the
streams we've done. I like this format. And
then you guys could just, like, banter about
whatever and then they actually, like, jump in
on things. This is you get a three
three person format
for TBS now. Yeah. No. I really think
the three people is really good because, like
you were saying, someone can be doing work.
Because, like, typically, if you have two people,
like, for instance, if it's just you and
Marcus, if Marcus is writing the code, like,
if you're asking him questions, it's gonna be
hard for him to focus on what he's
doing as well as engaging and have, like,
a conversation that's entertaining to viewers.
But this way, we kind of get a
a background track while people are watching Marcus'
work. Yeah.
Alright. So let's what what is it you're
doing right now, Mark? I wanna make you
talk with you both know that that Dan
just said that. So
we've got project ID, and you're just gonna
we're just gonna try and print a list
of devices. Oh, no. You're actually deleting them.
I mean Oh, yeah. No. This is yeah.
Hard hardcore. This
there's no going back here. We're gonna delete
everything
that might exist. So what things could exist
inside of a project?
Devices,
elastic IPs.
Yeah. Let's get rid of those two. Volumes.
Let's just get a I'm gonna go with
the generic
letter since
yeah. Alright. No. I guess not. Yeah. So
When you copy and paste in code, do
I get the get the
singular not the plural?
So I'm not the world's best gold developer,
but I'm assuming those red squiggly lines been
bad.
Oh, yeah. Well, let's see what I did
wrong.
Project list.
Two, there's a response that I don't care
about.
There we go.
And, obviously, I'm not checking for error. It's,
you know, what could go wrong? Yellow.
Let's do this.
So, Dan, do you understand
why we're building this? Did we could could
we make that clear, or do want me
to go over that again?
I I got the basic. I missed the
very beginning of the stream.
But, essentially, what this is supposed to be
a GitHub action, right, that does some checking
for things and packet related projects?
Yeah. So as we do more and more
end to end testing, we just need the
ability to have, like, these ephemeral projects and,
like, be able to clean them up. And
the API would allow you to remove a
project if it has any resources.
Gotcha. We just need to be able to
work out what those are, delete them. I'm
assuming we're gonna have to actually wait for
those to be deleted too before we eventually
remove the projects.
Yeah. I can't remember. Are these calls synchronous
or asynchronous when you make a delete call
here in the in the SDK?
I
I'm not a % sure. I think
I think that they trigger events that we
might have to follow. Mhmm.
Yeah. But that that would definitely that'll be
a problem for this. Something to figure out
next. Some looks like if you had something
that was continuously
reconciling the state of these things,
that that would be helpful.
What are you what are you suggesting, Tim?
I don't know. This is probably called cross
plane that might be useful. I don't know.
It seems like kind of heavy handed, right,
to, like, spin up a, like, a kind
cluster install cross plane and then, you know,
something to delete these things. But one of
the things that I've been thinking about a
lot lately and and not just me, other
folks in the cross plane community is, like,
if you could package
essentially, like, a a Docker image that was
kind,
cross plane, and then, like, you know, a
provider of your choice, then you could essentially
just run a single container and do, like,
almost like a,
you know, like a cron job or something
that ran, like, this the provider temporarily to
do things like cleanup like this or something
like that.
You know, I don't know what if there
would be
as many use cases as I'm thinking right
now,
but it would be something for sure to
experiment with and also could be useful for,
you know, local development and that sort of
thing.
I'm
surprised that is there not, like, a mock
Kubernetes
API server that could be used so you
could maybe run-in for a claim as I
was spending up a field with growing cluster
or API?
Yeah. So
sort of, yes. One of the things
that
you can actually do with crosswind is run
it in a tenant mode,
which allows you to essentially
run the
you know, like, if you're running controllers and
stuff like that, you have to actually have
infrastructure for that to run on in a
cluster to schedule that and that sort of
thing. You have to have a full cluster.
But then if you are actually just using
an API server to,
you know, for those providers to interact with,
you don't actually need that scheduling capability. All
you need is basically the API server and
a backing data store, typically, at CD. So
you could run a a very stripped down
Kubernetes,
which is basically just those two components
that essentially your providers would watch
and interact with because all that's doing is
basically storing state for you, right, and allowing
you to get that. So it's not fully
mocked because you are actually still running, like,
the, like, etcd and that sort of thing,
but you can run it, you know, for
instance, we have some end to end tests
that are using, like, the cube builder type
thing where you're actually just executing the binaries
behind the scenes
and talking to those.
And then those are running in a those
end to end tests are running into, a
cotton cluster or something like that.
So, yeah, that's definitely something
to look at there. I'd be interested in
a kind of like a CICD pipeline is
a a cool place to look at doing
that. So any GitHub action would be even
simpler because folks could just kinda, like, add
that to their project immediately.
That's a lot of to do statements. Yeah.
And what I realized in writing the to
dos is that I'm not gonna care about
any of the rest of this right now.
I'm just gonna care about deleting the devices.
Oh, yeah. Because we can just create a
project. I'll do that in there.
Yeah.
I'll create a project with one device,
and then we can just run it.
Yeah. So let's see what's device delete. It's
not checked. You'll find and delete a a
real server checks
with code that you've read in another three
and a half minutes.
Yeah. Do all of these
underlying clients implement this? They don't implement the
same interface. Right? So you can't just, like,
pass them in and just call delete on
all of them? Because their parameter
yeah.
Their their parameters are different. I wish. I
wish.
And, usually, when you want something like that,
you need to, like, pass in some sort
of function to do it or or set
of functions. Yeah.
That'd something you need to work after.
What is
What is the dot dot dot of
of functions that you would use as parameters?
What's the right go for terminology for that?
I would just call it, like, parameter expansion,
which I don't think is what Yeah. The
JavaScript and
another language, is just called the spread operator.
Yeah.
Yeah. I don't let me actually I'll look
that up
since I'm just the the guest here. I
I can be the the researcher as well.
But here's a random one for you, and
while you're doing that. Like, I've been writing
a lot more Rust this year,
and they have an operator called the TurboFish.
Have you seen the TurboFish?
Mhmm.
It's like this weird syntax for generic
functions.
I'll need to paste this somewhere. I'm not
gonna be able to describe what it looks
like, but it's the weirdest thing I've seen
in code in a long time.
Alright, Marcus.
I'm sending you an API key.
Oh,
is this for for my purposes here?
Yeah. For just so that you don't have
to wait on spending up a project. I
figured I would just just provide you. Do
you have a resource in there? I should
probably print what I'm deleting if that's the
case. There's a server called
1 T 1 Small X 80 6 0
1. Yes.
And you don't care if I delete it.
Right?
I do not mind if you delete it.
No. And I've sent you the project ID.
So you should have everything you need. And
I'll in fact, you'll oh, I created a
product a project API key. So, you know
So that should be better than right. You
you can delete the device, but you won't
be able to delete the project, I would
imagine.
Also, the official name for the the kind
of spread and go lang is very variadic
function parameters.
That's what waiting for. Variadic. I couldn't remember
that.
So that's our delete c calls it as
well.
Variate it. And we should wait for them,
but we'll maybe skip the waiting for now.
And what else do we wanna do?
Gonna delete them. I need to get into
a terminal
and handy way to
read in secrets
that somebody passes you in Slack
maybe we need to do this.
I can just type in whatever, and we're
good to go. Follow it up with a
clear right where the neck up.
It'd be wonderful. And now I'm gonna grab
that secret that you handed me.
Password,
one two three. Got it.
And
project ID,
it's same thing.
That one, did not
prompt it properly.
Let's do that again.
Okay.
I've got a project ID. I've got a
packet auth token. So let's see. Go run.
Yeah. What could go wrong? YOLO.
I love how you're not even commenting out
the delete. You're actually just gonna wait and
see what happens.
Alright. I need to give this thing a
name. Okay.
Github.com/display/packetproject.
What did I not comment, though?
What did say?
Arguments.
Which one? Is it the true? I thought
that it took a force true.
Oh, it doesn't. What happened? Devices delete.
Always trust the red speckle. Like, that's just
the rule.
Yeah. I thought I thought there was a
a force parameter to force it to detect.
I guess that's something that the the packet
UI does manually,
and this is something that, you know, definitely
needs to be improved as the the documentation
on each function.
Okay.
Packet
off to I read it, but I didn't
export it.
So I'll do this,
and I probably need to do the Symfony
project ID.
I think that an output
I assume your device has not been deleted.
Let's see what happened.
It didn't panic, though. It's a good sign.
But why is there a red square to
one device? Oh, yeah. What's the problem is
here?
Oh, because it's the it's not inside the
next bar. Right? Yeah.
Could you not just return earlier? I mean,
I don't wanna give you a shit for
your code not being very ergonomic, but come
on.
Do want me to exit early? Alright. Alright.
Fine.
I I just I have, like, this really
strong
hatred for else statements in any any code
at all. So Yeah. The
Golang
Yeah. You have the chance to there is
no yeah. The Golang went through probably would've
yelled at me for that too.
The Golang
CI went.
Alright. So now we're good.
So does the panic do an exit, or
do you have to return? Panic exits. Yeah.
It's fatal.
And there's no
yeah.
Do I need to return? It has a
complaint about needing a a bare return.
Nice. Cool. So now let's just dockerize this
and publish it in the GitHub actions. How
do you do that? We have five minutes.
Go.
It's gone. Like, there you go. It deleted.
Alright. So next step is publishing.
Let's get you back up.
Alright.
So we need a
Dockerfile,
and we need ARM 64 support. So, you
know, don't get lazy.
We all devices in project, by the way.
That's
what I wanna do. Mark
is agreeing that the red squiggle doesn't lie.
Well said.
Alright. So packet project, we've got that. So
what do we have instructions? Do you have
anybody dig up a link on how to
make a Docker
a
GitHub action friendly Dockerfile?
I assume it needs to be a Docker
file.
So, yeah, you have to build a container
image,
and I believe it has to be wrapped.
Like, all the examples I've seen before, was
hold on. I do understand.
It's generally, like, JavaScript fails, but then execs
out for the shell and runs a binary,
which is not great.
But that seems just to be the way
that it's done.
Let's see.
So there is a Cypress
oh, that's a big one.
Do we actually need an entry point shell
script, or is it enough to just run
the thing that we've compiled?
You should just go to run it directly
if you built it.
Wait. Are you are you building
I assume you're building it in the
in the image as well. So I
So I'm building oh, yeah. There's a main
site to make a builder staged.
Yeah. Well, I guess you don't have to
since this is just a a quick stream.
But Yeah. You could just do from this
builder and then copy it over to a
scratch image or something like that or just
drill us. Right. Any quick can't Scratch images.
Let's see. What was that, Marcus? Just looking
for any kind of quick examples I can
find of that. If only I knew a
project that uses Scratch
Docker
image. Yeah. Or you can just do it
from scratch. You don't need to do anything
special. I can walk you through that.
That's problem. Your Docker file?
Yeah.
Yeah. So just at the very yeah. Just
do it from scratch. That's it. But we're
still building.
The next one could be from
think we'd still wanna use Alpine for both,
but but I want is, like, the stage.
We wanna be able to copy it from
a build stage to a
to the So you can do a front
go line at the top, copy on all
the codes, then do a run go build,
and then fill that through in the next
stage. Yeah.
I'm going
do you wanna copy everything or it's already
here? It's already here? Just
copy main dot go.
And and the and the go mod and
the go to Just do dot dot.
Dot dot. Yeah. Okay. And then we want
to run.
Oh, build.
All good for the build cache. Now when
you change the read me, we're have to
recompile all that full 10 lines of code
we've got there.
Have you staged it?
Sorry? How do you stage this now? So
you can reference that as from zero or
after the from goal line, you can do
it as built, which is what I would
tend to do. And then that means it's
named as built. So from Golang space, a
s build. And
then you can copy from build now.
So from scratch there.
You guys don't like debugging.
I need that out on the shelf. And
then in your copy packet
project down there, you can do a a
dash dash from before your arguments. Right. Right.
I guess the output is it packet project?
It goes. Or is it just gonna be
main, I guess? So from equals build? Yeah.
That's good.
And there's no working directories in the top
one. I can't remember where it go. Does
it? I think it's slash go slash source.
Mhmm.
Yeah. I think it's slash go slash source.
We may have to confirm that.
Who needs a language server when you have
me and David live commenting here?
We are we are your squiggly lines.
Alright. So
do you think I need something else? Or
do think we've got what we need here?
Yeah. So the copy is not gonna work.
The so it's gonna be slash go slash
short slash
And then is it just gonna be called
main? I forget what the default is. I
haven't done a not dash o.
I mean, like, is the binary just gonna
be called main?
You know what I mean, Marcus?
Yeah.
I'm gonna see if
I would probably add one echo PWD or
something like that or so you can see
where it's building that Yeah. Because that path
is a guess. So
it's PWD.
Yeah. I think I think that it's gonna
be in Go source
slash I mean, it's just gonna be called
Go source main
likely.
So this is what the container looks like.
If I copy dot, it went into Go
was the default directory. Right.
So
should I worry about should if it's going
to the Go directory, does it matter?
We go back out to the Go directory
and see oh, wait. It didn't copy it
over, though, did it? I didn't. I just
ran.
Oh, I see. I see. Mhmm.
So you could copy it into source if
you wanted, but
oh, also, is it?
Oh, it's nine. Yeah. I'm gonna be here
in just a minute. Yeah. We gotta run
away too. But
I think, like, you you you did well.
You got really far in, like, under thirty
minutes. Yeah.
Don't know. Too long. There's so much there's
a lot of the
the mental
bifurcation.
Alright. Well, I guess we better go to
our meeting, but we will continue this next
week. So thank you both for joining me,
and thank you for taking all that code
markers. Catch
you all soon.
Yeah. See you.